>> IT'S TIME FOR, IT WAS THE
WORST OF TIMES, IT WAS THE WORST
OF TIMES.
IT'S TIME TO ANGERLY SWIPE
EVERYTHING OFF THE NIGHT STAND.
TOMORROW DONALD TRUMP IS
RELEASING HIS BOOK "CRIPPLED
AMERICA, HOW TO MAKE AMERICA
GREAT AGAIN."
I HAVE TO BE HONEST I HAVEN'T
READ IT YET.
BUT I'M GUESSING ALL THE PAGES
LOOK LIKE THIS.
[LAUGHING]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> NOW COMEDIANS SINCE I'M NOT
SURE WE WILL ALL READ THIS RIGHT
AWAY, I WOULD LIKE YOU TO BE OUR
CLIFFSNOTES AND GIVE US AS MANY
CHAPTERS FROM THIS BOOK AS YOU
CAN IN 60 SECONDS AND BEGIN.
>> VIETNAM, PAYING TAXES AND
OTHER THINGS I'VE AVOIDED.
>> WHY I WROTE A BOOK WHEN ALL
MY FANS ARE ILLITERATE.
>> POINTS.
>> WHY I HATE ALL IMMIGRANTS
EXCEPT MY MOTHER AND MY WIVES.
>> ELIZA.
>> DUMB BROADS WHO THINK I'M
CHAUVINISTIC.
>> POINTS. DAVE HILL.
>> FIVE MEXICANS I'M NOT EXACTLY
CRAZY ABOUT.
>> POINTS.
ELIZA.
>> PENELOPE CRUZ AND OTHER
HISPANICS WHO CAN STAY.
>> DAVE HILL.
>> FIVE THINGS I WOULD USE A
MEXICAN FOR IF I ABSOLUTELY HAD
TO.
>> COMB, PRAY, LOVE.
>> FIVE PEOPLE I THOUGHT WERE
MEXICAN WHO TURNED OUT TO NOT BE
MEXICAN.
>> POINTS.